we've been doing quite a few experiments
with acids and
you the viewers
made
real popular requests that we should try
using piranha solution
neil and i
never use piranha solution didn't even
know what it was
but
we've made it
and the results have been fantastic
all sorts of exciting things including a
magnificent experiment with neil's
banana
piranha solution
is a mixture
not a very precise mixture of hydrogen
peroxide solution
and concentrated sulfuric acid
it's really important not to have an
excess of hydrogen peroxide at any time
or the solution can be potentially
explosive so you have a volume of
sulfuric acid and you add
about a quarter of that volume of
hydrogen peroxide solution these
experiments are potentially very
dangerous
and you must definitely not try them
yourselves you should watch our video
instead when you mix the solutions they
get
very hot
and you start seeing bubbling
almost certainly due to some of the
hydrogen peroxide
decomposing to oxygen and water we began
quite modestly
neil tried a flower
which disappeared
pretty quickly
[Music]
he then tried
a
berry
from a rowan tree
amusingly
neither brady nor neil knew what sort of
tree it was
and surprisingly
this berry
obviously was being attacked
but nothing very exciting happened
but then
they tried a couple of skittles
small sweets
and they were amazing
the reactions
have what is called an induction period
that means nothing seems to happen and
then bush
everything takes off
so if you see
these two sweets
swimming around in the solution
and then suddenly the reaction starts
and the reaction generates heat so it
goes faster and it goes faster and
faster
and the first stage
appears to be
the
concentrated sulfuric acid removing the
elements of water h2o
from the sugar in the sweet and
generating very finely divided carbon
which is black
so the solution goes a sort of blackish
brown color now what's really
interesting about the piranha solution
is that it can oxidize the carbon to co2
so this black solution
gradually goes
lighter and lighter pale yellow and
eventually colorless
[Music]
so you have something that is really
surprising for chemists
where you have
solids
that just disappear when you put them
into solution like they've been eaten by
piranhas
yes except
with piranhas you see fat fish of course
chemists always like to scale up their
reactions
so
neil took a whole handful of skittles
lots of different colors and the first
part of the reaction went rather more
violently
[Music]
you can see with the thermal image it
generates a lot of heat
and they're hot gases flowing out of the
top of the beaker
[Music]
the reaction
stopped
at the
carbon stage
because
the hydrogen peroxide
i think just ran out because there
wasn't a very large volume of solution
[Music]
neil then
got out a mars bar all right let's get
some mars bar in there
and his fantastic knife
in which he chopped off a piece of mars
bar quite a large piece
it went into rather a gooey mess
because i think there was just too much
sugar and chocolate to be completely
destroyed by the volume of piranha
solution that he made
you'll notice that neil's been quite
careful and not making a very large
volume at any one time because of the
danger of the solution and at the end of
each
experiment he pours all the solution
into sodium carbonate
which neutralizes this sulfuric acid
and just liberates co2 so it becomes
slightly alkaline
which will
make the hydrogen peroxide or any
residual hydrogen peroxide much less
oxidizing brady produced a banana
and
neal chopped off quite a modest piece
and neil put it in a fresh
piranha solution and it reacted really
quite well i think because banana is
soft and has quite a lot of sugar in it
[Music]
and so it reacted and again
we got a lot of carbon
[Music]
and like the skittles it more or less
disappeared
did the job on it didn't it we got a bit
more ambitious
and neil was persuaded to put the entire
banana
skin and all
into the solution
there was mayhem
everywhere
i think
that the fine particles of carbon
cause more frothing they stabilize
bubbles so it all bubbles up much more
and
solution went all over the inside of
neil's fume cupboard
[Music]
i was amazed
i've never seen such
destruction from a relatively small
amount of solution
so it was really quite a big cleanup job
before we could try
the experiment we really wanted to do
which was to try yet another chicken leg
well if you like watching science
experiments why not do some of your own
with our episode sponsor mel science
i'm delving into the world of mel
chemistry this free starter kit contains
all the essentials
and then with a subscription you get
these monthly boxes filled with
experimental goodness today i'm going
for the tin kit in particular creating
the tin hedgehog
it's well explained educational
definitely appealing to my inner child
my wannabe scientist
[Music]
here's some professional footage
but i was also pretty happy with my own
a bit later my hedgehog floated to the
top of the test tube really got me
thinking about what was going on
was it the bubbles
more experiments may be required this
strikes me as a great family activity
not just for aspiring chemists but
anyone who's just a bit curious
it's also exciting knowing a new box of
goodies is coming every month more
experiments mysteries knowledge fun to
be had
and here's a bonus get a 50 discount on
your first box by following the
instructions in our video description
and using our discount code it's all
down there have a look
they also do physics experiments and
have all sorts of other great stuff for
you to explore check out the mel science
website and thanks to them for
supporting this video
[Music]